hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Disney
has certainly gone through its ups and
downs in terms of TV hasn't it the SSA
wasn't always the onslaught of popular
sitcom slash rock star Barbie dolls it
is today example Disney once had a
two-hour block of programming called the
Disney Afternoon it started off strong
with shows like duck tails tail span and
ship and Dale Rescue Rangers but after a
while the show started to slip in
popularity with less successful programs
like wag bag bonkers and that show them
let's never be named so Disney decided
to take an approach they had never done
before an action series something that
had no talking animals or cutesy
scenarios that Disney was usually
associated with their answer was a
surprisingly well-written series simply
known as Darwin
often seen this Disney's answer to the
Batman cartoon gargoyles was dark
serious and very complex the stories
were epic and the characters were
fleshed out
well it's Gambrell so why was gargoyle
such a kick-ass show
lots of reasons and you probably wanna
know what they are
so let's stretch out our wings and fly
right into gargoyles so it starts out in
present-day New York and splits the
debris or drop down upon passing by
Stander's so they call up detective
ELISA maza to investigate the only cop
who for some reason has blue hair
connection she's curious as to what
could be causing all that horrible
destruction
what could be strong enough to leave
comics and solid stone it's worth the
lineage of the sparks goes on for
several years in fact we predate the
dinosaurs indeed
so we flash back a thousand years ago to
Scotland where the ancient battle for
this castle I guess is being fought by
where the hell these guys are because
they really really want it I don't know
there's like no detail on this backstory
it's just people with swords doing what
people with swords to keep any guy a
sword and you want to go pillage
something take me and take my legs but
they'll never take our questions we live
in Asia
but it turns out those stone gargoyles
aren't just there for decoration by
daytime they're stone but when the Sun
Goes Down they break through the rock
and become the defenders of the castle
so they're like stone vampires no no I
didn't mean like that clever mind so the
leader of the clan is called
Goliath who I swear his the coolest
freakin voice of all time you
trespassing then not far ahead I can
scare those cards away without any help
I don't know who that actor's wife is by
that she plays a lot of seventies music
when he's around there's other gargoyles
too but for some reason they don't have
names because they just associate them
by their common action team stereotypes
what is it are we being attacked again
cool it's the bat one tricks are very
light for horses Carrie gone mad min how
you doing over there old one not afraid
are you I can see why my the prissy one
is in rare form today let us go out in
force and put an end to these pigs once
and for all
hey how are you doing incredibly big boo
bead one oh there's also a gargoyle dog
how the hell does that work I mean other
gargoyle cats too my guess is it's not
really a dog but a normal gargoyle that
was just born with special needs leave
him alone he just likes to walk like
that so I guess the castle is run by the
princess insert pretty name here I took
the liberty of asking them to appear and
be recognized for their bravery we are
most seriously displeased to allow
beasts in a dining hall
these are unnatural creatures no good
can come from associating with them
except saving our asses on a daily basis
hi I mean I know prejudice get stronger
the further back you go but why do they
hate these guys they make how security
systems look like the tracks from home
alone you are as good a soldier as the
Philistine giant who fought David you do
well too
member captain that the biblical Goliath
was also a bully and a savage to be fair
they only eat five school children are
we better than Elias we owe you our
lives as we owe you ours every day
but all was not meant to be when the
each room itical story continues drug
abuse and thousand-year-old curses for
indeed there is trouble about Escalades
best human friend leads him away from
the castle so he can sabotage the
weapons though I find up too late as the
Sun rises and freezes our heroes
do they ever freeze in an embarrassing
pose like one of them is just standing
there taking of ways and then suddenly
oh shit the Sun mother so the bad guy
stormed the castle take everybody
prisoner and even destroy all the stone
statues of the gargoyles yeah maybe you
should have oh I don't know hear
yourselves or something
I mean why display yourselves in the
middle of the day in plain vulnerable
sight that's pretty cocky guys do you
also make taunting motions before the
Sun comes up so the life returns and
finds all his warrior smashed into
cigarette butts there's only three
others who survived as well that weird
gargling of dog because they were sealed
in a hidden shelter earlier so the
gargoyles take what's left of their clan
and do a hunt down for vengeance well
the bad guys talked with the princess
and her wizardly Legolas impersonator
Hugh black no my spells no which one of
these fair maidens do you want I don't
take the albino she has far more
delicate features but the princess
escapes as the GAR goes flying to whip
some Viking ish ass
love jewel motherfuckers ooh but the
wizard guy thinks the princess is dead
and the gargoyles are to blame so he
casts a spell on them to turn them into
stone permanently but in actuality the
lion seats the princess while the
villains slip off a cliff to their
deaths you know for Disney cartoon a lot
of people sure do get the axe
this is like five Simba fathers and
three Bambi mothers I've been denying
everything even my river and on top of
that I think I have a spoon well at
least nothing else can go wrong oh god
what sorcery is this
so the wizard realizes his mistakes and
regrets that he can't reverse the spell
he turned him to stone forever the terms
of the spell were that they would sleep
until the castle rises above the clouds
granted it's a weak loophole by a holdup
nonetheless so yeah it hasn't exactly
been the best week for Goliath does he
tells the wizard to Casas fell one last
time so he can at least be reunited with
his frozen brothers connection cut two
years later when a millionaire named
xanto's played by Riker from Star Trek
actually goes to the trouble of raising
the castle above the clouds resulting in
probably the most epic yawn of all time
boy
you are the one called Goliath yes but
my friends call me go how long has it
been this may be a shock a thousand
years have gone by since the spell was
cast The Magus who cursed you wrote the
whole story down in there I was
fascinated by the megasis story I wanted
to see if it was true why have you done
all this I'm eccentric so Santos
explains all about this new world
adventure want detective bonza from
earlier explores what was causing all
that falling debris sorry pal but this
investigation isn't over yet don't tell
me this is where Dracula shows up good
laugh would be worth a lot of money
right about now you know for a snoop I
certainly talk to myself a lot
look-alike dives down and catches her
and does his best to explain who they
are my kind have no names but you humans
call me
Goliath your kind you mean there's more
than one of you barely we treat the
mentally disabled one as a dog so I
don't know if that counts so he climbs
back up the building carrying her along
with it boy no Kate so that part just
happened but she does befriend the
gargoyles and becomes sort of the April
O'Neil of the group you know if April
was packing this starts off a quasi
romance between Goliath and ELISA which
I always thought was kind of weird I
mean what would the kids look like no no
not guys think about not just race it
from my memory
Billy how do my money ever does when I
tell it to so if there's ever a time
traveling fish-out-of-water story you
know there's got to be a few scenes
where they interact comically with
modern technology but to the shield's
credit it's pretty downplayed they
usually only do it when these three are
around you suppose this does
and let's decide that the gargoyles
really do need names so they decide to
name themselves after the famous city
landmarks the sky need to knee does the
river the river is called the Hudson
fine lass then I will be the Hudson as
well because it's all dirty and often
very smelly just like me
booklet I'm Brooklyn Broadway Lexington
do you like it they're all fine names I
guess he'll need one as well now oh I've
got one for him too
heal me New York metropolitan sewer
system your Bronx I think he likes it by
the way am I the only one that thought
Lexington should have been made queasy
oh my god stop pickin on it so in a
surprise twist Goliath old flame returns
as well only this time she's called
Damona voiced by another Star Trek actor
in London play Troy except she's not
quite as Goliath remembers her and she
wants revenge on All Humans because of
how they betrayed her clan we have no
human friends nor should we humanity is
a poison that must be purged from this
planet I want you to get rid of the
humans humanity is our enemy Goliath
yeah but we make such good point you
gotta give us that like a female Magneto
Damona actually becomes one of the great
cartoon villains always vengeful and
always cold
with that great brooding boys if you are
not my allies and you are my enemy
it turns out Santos becomes a villain
too always had your diabolical schemes
to gain more power and control but
always think suave its savvy go ahead
without me you'd still be gathering boss
such as the planted garbage says they
constantly fight not only demands
anecdotes but a whole slew of other
fatties the stories were sometimes
episodic but mostly intertwined the best
ones being about de motives past and how
she survived all these centuries for
example there's one episode where de
moto goes back in time and tries to
convince herself to kill Goliath and
rage war in all humanity but the hopeful
Damona of the past doesn't want to
believe that she becomes the vengeful
Damona of the future this is actually a
really clever idea the humans did this
and you can stop it destroy all the
humans rule the gargoyles rule the world
I am what you will become
I will never be like you ah I do not
wish to hurt you and I do not wish to be
you and I don't wish for you to hurt you
why lump you you there's also episodes
with mythical characters like King
Arthur puck but again they don't make
them as cheesy as it sounds they
actually give them the dignity that a
lot of these myths already had that's
pretty impressive for a kids show but I
think my favorite episode is the one
called future tense where Goliath
arrives in the future and all hell broke
loose as zanatos has apparently taken
over trying to set things right
all the gargoyles get killed and
slaughtered by Xena toeses army but then
it turns out Santos is really a computer
with all the memories of the original
person but then it turns out it wasn't
Santos at all it was Lexington who's
become overtaken by badness but then it
turns out it was all an illusion by punt
to try to get a mythical emblem from
Goliath and then it turns out it may or
may not have been a dream and it turns
out that Goliath is a woman
okay that didn't happen but you get the
idea this show was filled with plot
twists and surprise endings that
actually all seem to add up
it didn't seem forced or contrived this
just might be fun after all oh by the
way did I mention that punk is voiced by
data also from Star Trek good god they
should just make the Christ look like
this
after the first two seasons were such a
big hit they went into their next and
final season called the Goliath
Chronicles this is where I kind of
remember getting weird
it wasn't horrible but just wasn't as
strong as it used to be
Santos is now a full-time friend Damona
was rarely seen and the villains were
replaced by these weird sort of gargoyle
KKK rejects called weary men that's
really lame
the stories were a lot weaker too for
example there's an episode where
Broadway becomes a TV star and another
one where Goliath actually goes on trial
I wouldn't be surprised if there was an
episode entitled shark jumping in-you
but I remember the original shows and
they were always gripping and clever
it's funny because this show came on
when I was in the middle of high school
around the point when you kind of stop
watching kids cartoons
so the rare time someone would mention
the show I feel like God won't and what
I don't know any guy fun secret I would
actually watch everyone because it was
just that good
I don't know if it really changed
anything in terms of kid shows like
Batman or Animaniacs but was certainly a
welcome detour from what Disney usually
it really stood on its own and created
some really wonderful and really unique
stories gargoyles is a blast from the
past that is sure to live on in the
future I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so a hero hat